[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour un mix plume
un petit peu différente d'habitude parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de script on
va on va faire une sorte de podcasts sur
un sujet qui me tient plutôt à coeur
voilà qui est qui et la conservation des
espèces alors je pense que certains
d'entre vous ne ne sont pas sans savoir
que mon job c'est la conservation des
espèces donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui m'intéresse qui me passionne
et ça c'est quelque chose dont je
voulais vous parler parce qu'il ya un
concept il n'y a pas si longtemps qu'ils
y qu'a commencé à faire surface
normand qui a été définie en 2013 si je
me suis un bien et qui fait de plus en
plus débat sur entre les spécialistes et
aussi sur les réseaux du coup il
commence à être un peu plus démocratisé
et qui s'appelle la conservation
compassionnel mais vous l'entendrez
surtout avec le terme anglais qui est
complète contre ce match donc si vous
recherchez ça sur le net vous verrez des
avis divers et variés sur le sujet et
c'est quelque chose qui à mon avis va
prendre de plus en plus d'ampleur que ce
soit chez les gens qui font de la
conservation donc comme moi mais aussi
pour le grand public parce que c'est un
sujet qui est très tendance en ce moment
donc c'est pour ça que je vois là
j'avais envie de vous en parler un petit
peu mais alors sans artifice sans rien
du tout juste comme une sorte de
podcasts voilà donc prenez un thé un
café ce que vous voulez et puis bah
voilà on va discuter un petit peu alors
pour commencer je pense qu'il est
important de définir le mot conservation
parce qu'on sait plus où moins de quoi
il s'agit on entend parler tout le temps
mais on sait pas vraiment de manière
pratique en quoi ça consiste donc la
conservation la définition c'est la
protection de la biodiversité des
facteurs qui met en danger cette
biodiversité ou qui renforce les dangers
qui pèsent déjà sur les espèces donc
c'est une définition qui datent de 85 et
qui est toujours en application
aujourd'hui parce que ben voilà on a
toujours des espèces qui disparaissent
des espèces qui ont besoin qu'on les
aide un petit peu à surmonter certains
certains problèmes généralement causée
par l'humain est donc cette définition
est tout à fait d'actualité alors les
dangers généralement c'est des dangers
qui ont des causes humaines on va pas se
mentir la plupart des temps j'ai auquel
les espèces font face en ce moment c'est
directement ou indirectement d'origine
humaine un malheureusement quand vous
avez des destructions d'habitats quand
vous avez de la pollution quand vous
avez
des destructions carrément d'espèces par
le braconnage par exemple c'est
évidemment de source humaine
malheureusement et donc tous ces
problèmes tous ces dangers qu'on fait
peser sur les espèces c'est un peu aussi
notre rôle d'essayer de les minimiser et
d'essayer de de les réduire au maximum
pour faire en sorte que les espèces
survie donc c'est un peu ça le boulot
d'une personne qui fait de la
conservation c'est d'essayer de faire
survivre les espèces en identifiant les
dangers auxquels elle est soumise et
voilà en essayant de les minimiser au
maximum voire dans le meilleur des cas
de les effacer complètement ce qui est
généralement
plutôt impossible voilà on va en parler
un petit peu plus tard donc la
conservation on va se baser sur
différentes méthodes en fonction la
situation en fonction des problèmes qui
vont peser sur une espèce on n'a pas
utilisé la même méthode pour la protéger
ce sera inutile d puis aussi en fonction
de l'espèce en elle même toutes les
méthodes n'ont pas fonctionné voilà donc
vous avez en total douze catégories de
dangers qui peuvent peser sur les
espèces évidemment les plus importants
vont être la pollution alors on parle
généralement de pollution chimique ce
qu'on va déverser dans la rivière il va
en produits pour loin eux mêmes mais on
a aussi toutes les pollutions sonores
visuelles olfactives tout ça c'est aussi
catégoriser dans la pollution parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'espèces qui vont
voir leur cycle perturbé par ba soit de
la lumière en pleine nuit par exemple
arte normalement et n'a pas soit des
bruits qui vont perturber par exemple
les issambres production chez les
oiseaux c'est quelque chose d'assez
d'assez important notamment ville on a
des oiseaux dans le cycle va être
perturbée simplement parce qu'il ya
beaucoup trop de bruit en ville donc il
faut pas arriver à finir leur cycle de
reproduction correctement la niche il va
être abandonnée en format plein de
problèmes vous avez en autres catégories
dedans j'ai évidemment la destruction ou
la perte d'habitat pour l'espèce donc
dans ce cas là ça équivaut aussi à une
mise à mort parce que si vous perdez
votre maison typiquement c'est difficile
d'en trouver une autre et même si vous
en trouvez une autre il n'est pas dit
qu'elle ne soit déjà habité par
quelqu'un et dans ce cas là il est
impossible pour vous de l'occuper vous
avez aussi le braconnage pour la
destruction d'espèce protégée par
exemple parce que bon on va utiliser les
parties des animaux pour un peu tout et
n'importe quoi que soit la médecine que
cela l'alimentation que ce soit utilisé
pour pour les fourrures court of voilà
pour l'apparat il ya plein de choses
comme ça et puis vous avez aussi les
espèces invasives qui est aussi une
destruction causée par l'humain en ce
sens que ba l'humain généralement
apporte avec lui des espèces qu'ils
soient par exemple les chats et les
chiens domestiques ou bien des dira même
comme ça s'est passé c'est que le
dernier on sait que d'avant quand les
grands voyageurs ont commencé par quoi
le globe ils sont transportés dans la
cale de leur navire et ben deja qui ont
ensuite débarqué sur les îles sur
lesquels débarquer les colons voilà donc
sans le savoir ils ont aussi amené avec
eux des espèces invasives des rats des
souris normales tout ce genre de choses
les deux grandes catégories de
conservation au niveau des actions qu'on
peut effectuer donc vous avez des
actions qui vont être effectués in situ
donc c'est à dire sur le site même où
résident l'espèce naturellement nous par
exemple si vous avez une forêt qui est
mise en danger par une action x ou y
vous allez titre protéger la forêt en
elle même si c'est encore possible si
elle n'est pas détruite et éléments dont
vous allez affecter les actions sur le
site même de la forêt pour essayer de
protéger les espèces qu'ils y habitent
et vous avez aussi des actions qui vont
être effectués ex situ qui vont souvent
être synonyme de plus gros danger pour
l'espèce donc typiquement la forêt est
détruite les espèces qui vivaient à
l'intérieur sont en danger d'extinction
imagine donc c'était le seul site où
elle était présente sur terre non ces
cas là vous avez laissé récupérer les
derniers représentants de l'espèce en
question pour les faire se reproduire en
captivité pour peut-être plus tard et
bien avoir des programmes de
réintroduction dans un autre endroit où
il y aura une autre forêt qui leur
conviendra voilà donc ça c'est une
action qui sera excite uvic évidemment
elle ne se passe plus sur le site parce
que c'est plus possible tout simplement
voilà donc ça c'était pour les petites
définition concernant la conservation
j'espère que vous sachiez un peu plus de
quoi on parle pour que c'est toujours
important de définir les choses de prime
abord donc aujourd'hui pour parler de la
conservation compassionnel la compassion
michel on va s'intéresser principalement
aux cas d espèce invasive parce que
c'est un cac et qui fait beaucoup débat
de nos jours et c'est le cas sur lequel
généralement les avocats de la
conservation compassionnel vont être
vraiment en porte à faux avec les gens
qui font la conservation qui est plus
traditionnel on va dire pour commencer
on va essayer de définir la conservation
compassionnel parce que là je vous ai
fait la conservation traditionnelle en
quelque sorte niveau de la conservation
compassionnel on est sur des choses un
petit peu différente même si au final ça
se recoupent un peu évidemment on rêve
sur de la conservation des espèces donc
les grands principes en quelque sorte
vont êtres vont être là aussi mais vous
allez voir que dans les détails il y a
deux trois trucs qui vont vraiment
modifier la manière dont
dont on envisage la conservation donc la
conservation compassionnel la définition
elle même dit que c'est la conservation
qui s'occupent en priorité de la
protection des animaux en tant
qu'individu et pas juste en tant que
membre d'une espace ou d'une population
donc là on a vraiment la notion
d'individualités qui ressort dans cette
idée de conservation qui est très
différente du coût de la conservation
traditionnelle qui elle va protéger les
populations et les espèces voir les
écosystèmes donc des grands groupes en
quelque sorte donc c'est vraiment à ce
niveau là que la conservation
compassionnel va se différencier la
conservation traditionnel il ya déjà un
premier petit point avec cette
définition qui m'ennuie un petit peu
c'est que dans la conservation
traditionnel on a parlé de la protection
de la biodiversité donc au total donc on
parle de tout lé règne du vivant voilà
donc les animaux les plantes les
champignons les bactéries dans la
conservation compassionnel vous remarqué
que la définition ne s'intéresse qu'aux
animaux donc là a déjà on écarte une
grande partie du vivant et ça m'ennuie
un petit peu parce que quid des plantes
il ya beaucoup de plantes qui sont en
voie de disparition en voie d'extinction
même y sera intéressante si l'intéressé
un minimum ça c'était vraiment le
premier point de cette conservation
compassionnel se décline en quatre
points majeurs qui sont des points
éthique donc c'est vraiment basée sur
l'éthique la conservation compassionnel
donc le point numéro un ce sera ne pas
faire de mal le point numéro 2 les
individus sont importants donc à la
différence de
ce qu'on a vu dans la définition les
populations pour la conservation
traditionnel ici on part vraiment
d'individus dans la conservation
compassionnel point numéro 3
l'inclusivité de tous les individus sans
considération de santé de race d'espacé
et 4 la coexistence pacifique entre
l'humain et l'animal et ça aussi c'est
un point capital de la conservation
compassionnel c'est essayer de vivre en
paix avec valve écosystèmes qui nous
entoure en l'occurrence ici seulement
avec les animaux à l'eau réactions sur
fish comme d'habitude bon on y reviendra
alors ce que je vous propose de faire
c'est simplement de prendre les points
un par un et d'essayer de voir ce qui va
ou ce qui va pas avec et en quoi ça peut
clasher entre les deux types de
conservation et je vais essayer de vous
donner des exemples à chaque fois pour
pour appuyer mon propos des exemples de
conservation qui vont pouvoir essayer de
moualla d'éclairer un peu pourquoi est
ce que je dis ça et pas autre chose
on va commencer par le point numéro 1
sur logique ne pas faire de mal donc là
on revient directement à l'histoire du
serment d'hippocrate
le but c'est évidemment au maximum de ne
ne pas faire de mal à l'animal en
essayant de le sauver alors ça semble
logique un porte- mende et j'avoue que
là pour le coup on rejoint un peu la
conservation traditionnel c'est à dire
que là aussi la consommation
traditionnelle va se dire on va éviter
de faire du mal aux animaux qu'on essaie
de conserver ce serait quand même un peu
mieux de le faire correctement pour
sauvegarder un maximum d individus de
l'espèce qu'on veut sauver ce qui est
tout à fait logique le problème c'est
que encore une fois ici on oublie un
niveau c'est à dire que là on
s'intéresse uniquement à l'individu est
pas à la population en conservation
traditionnelle et ce qui va nous
intéresser c'est la santé de la
population au complet parce que c'est
cette population qu'on veut sauver vous
pouvez sauver un individu c'est très
bien mais si vous n'avez pas sauver le
reste de la population typiquement ça ne
sert à rien donc l'intérêt c'est
vraiment d'avoir la santé globale de la
population pour essayer de faire en
sorte que cette population survivent
alors le serment d'hippocrate c'est le
serment des médecins vous le savez ça
veut dire que le traitement médical va
être seulement utilisé lorsque les
bénéfices de ce traitement vont être
supérieur au coût du traitement c'est à
dire que vous pouvez en quelque sorte
faire un petit peu de mal aux patients à
conviction qu'après ils s'en sortent
typiquement vous allez faire une
opération vous allez ouvrir mais à la
fin il va s'en sortir enfin on essaye de
faire entendre qu'il s'en sorte donc il
ya une histoire de risques et bénéfices
dans l'idée
le problème c'est que ce principe est
appliqué entre le médecin et son unique
patience et à qui si on va traiter un
individu on ne traite pas une population
en entier le médecin s'intéresse à son
patient il va effectivement faire le
traitement en fonction du patient mais
il va pas faire le traitement en
fonction de la population en fonction de
sa famille en fonction de cela dont il
va faire le traitement sur le patient
sur un individu 6il en conservation ont
commencé à vous intéresser uniquement un
individu est pas à la population vous
allez oublier tout un tas de trucs et en
l'occurrence que vous avez oublié c'est
tout les relations entre ces individus
au sein de la population par exemple
mais vous allez aussi oublier toutes les
relations trop fixe mais tel que cette
population eh ben elle n'est pas toute
seule cette population de cette espèce
un profond de vous parler eh ben elle
vit dans un écosystème et bien dans
l'écosystème qui est rempli de relations
trop filles danser des relations entre
les différentes espèces alors c'est des
relations de proies prédateurs par
exemple lancer des relations de
parasites à haute c'est enfin bref c'est
tout un écosystème de relation que la
conservation très traditionnel prend en
compte généralement dans bad horse
qu'elle va faire et dans les actions
qu'elle va faire le problème du coût de
la conservation
compassionnel c'est que en s'intéressant
uniquement à l'individu on oublie tout
le reste et c'est un peu dommage donc ça
c'était le premier pointe vers le
serment d'hippocrate lui même pas oublié
à quoi il s'applique normalement il
n'est pas censé s'appliquer à la
conservation bon ça veut pas dire que la
conservation on essaie pour notamment de
faire du mal aux espèces mais ça veut
aussi dire que c'est pas forcément la
chose la plus appropriée à utiliser pour
pour les méthodes de conservation le
deuxième point à propos de ce ne pas
faire de mal c'est que il ya un petit un
petit souci c'est que des fois
notamment le cas d'espèces invasives ne
pas faire de mal si jamais vous
commencez à dire oui mais faut pas faire
de mal aux espèces qu'on considère
vous allez rencontrer un problème c'est
à dire que notamment dans le cas d
espèce invasive certaines fois il va
falloir s'occuper des espèces invasives
et s'en occuper ça veut dire soit les
délocaliser les remettre entre par soit
carrément les éliminer parce que des
fois ça va avoir un impact dévastateur
sur les écosystèmes
alors pour remettre les choses au clair
qu'est ce qu'une espèce invasive je
pense que peut-être qu'on aurait dû
commencer par là
une espèce invasive c'est une espèce
qu'il n'appartient pas à l'écosystème
dans lequel elle a été apportée c'était
une espèce qui normalement n'est pas là
qui généralement a été apportée par
l'homme et qui bat du fait qu'elle est
peut-être plus compétitive qu'elle est
plus capable que notre espèce d'occuper
une niche écologique qui va du coup
remplacer une espèce qui étaient déjà là
sur place avant ou carrément faire
disparaître d'autres espèces soit par
exemple en les mangeant preda temps
certains une certaine chose en arrivant
sur place
soit simplement en étant plus
compétitive et donc en utilisant mieux
les ressources de l'endroit comparé à
d'autres espèces et donc en faisant
disparaître les espèces qui elles
n'arrivent plus à trouver la nourriture
correctement vu que bas sont moins
compétitifs donc elle moins accès aux
ressources que la nouvelle espèce qui
vient de s'installer pour ça c'est une
espèce invasive et le problème c'est que
l'homme est responsable de
l'introduction de beaucoup d'espèces
invasives comme me l'a dit avant pas
forcément volontairement comme les rats
qui qui traversaient sur les navires
mais des fois aussi volontairement
typiquement l'exemple du chat domestique
l'exemple du chat domestique est un peu
un problème aux yeux c'est un sujet très
sensible dans notre société évidemment
on voit les chats comme nos petites
peluches nos amis de toujours comme
peut-être des rois ou des reines comme
au temps des pharaons je ne sais pas
mais en tous les cas on les voit comme
des choses qui sont très proches de nous
et donc ces choses étant très proches de
nous très familière on n'a pas envie de
leur faire de mal évidemment on n'a pas
envie de croire que ils peuvent faire du
mal à d'autres choses
et malheureusement le chat domestique
grâce à l'humain s'est répandu sur la
majorité du globe et aujourd'hui les
chats domestiques retourner à l'état
sauvage notamment en australie sont un
des problèmes majeurs de la biodiversité
à ces endroits là car ils bouffent
carrément tout ce qui leur passe sous la
patte que soit peu tirés qu'il petit
oiseau ou bas petits mammifères
évidemment et donc ils sont responsables
de la destruction de nombreuses espèces
et de l'extinction d'ailleurs de pas mal
d'espacé notamment en australie on à
l'extinction d'une vingtaine d'espèces
de petits mammifères déjà qu'ils sont
dus aux chats et évidemment sa demande
émane y faire un emploi quand même pas
au niveau des oiseaux et des lézards par
exemple on a aussi encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'espèces qui sont mises en
danger par la présence des chats
domestiques non parce que les
extinctions continue ça ne s'arrête pas
juste parce qu'on en a envie donc pour
reprendre cette histoire de conservation
compassionnel et ne pas faire de mal les
espèces invasives comme les chats
domestiques donc qui sont revenus plus
ou moins à l'état sauvage en quelque
sorte en australie qui sont quand même
une population de 2 estimée entre deux
et six millions de chats donc sauvage en
australie maintenant cause des dégâts
irréparables à l'écosystème et si on
n'agit pas tout de suite là maintenant
et là et bientôt il n'y aura plus
d'espèces locales pour pour venir se
plaindre en quelque sorte la
conservation compassionnel en réponse à
ce genre de problème donc les chats
domestiques a proposé de stériliser les
populations de chats sauvages et on voir
de les mettre dans des reçus j'ai enfin
bref toute une gamme de choses qui en
quelque sorte permettent ne pas éliminer
les animaux parce que vraiment le moto
c'est ne pas faire de mal donc on ne
doit absolument faire aucun mal à quelle
que soit l'espèce que soit une espèce
invasive une espèce qui est en voie
d'extinction ou n'importe quoi le but
c'est vraiment de ne pas tuer d'animaux
et de ne pas faire de mal au maximum le
problème dans le cas des chats
domestiques et de l'australie c'est que
on en est arrivé à un point où il si
vous voulez beaucoup d'espèces non plus
que quelques années avant leur
extinction finale quand vous avez entre
2 et 6 millions de prédateurs introduits
comme ça il ya un moment où l'écosystème
si vous voulez y tient plus c'est fini
de toute façon les espèces qui sont
prédaté vont s'éteindre et le problème
c'est que là la situation est vraiment
critique et si on n'agit pas là
maintenant tout de suite
ça sera un peu foutu pour vous donner un
exemple un chat va manger à peu près en
australie 1 c'est les chiffres qui
avaient été rapportés dont qu'un chat
sauvage en moyenne de manger 740 petites
proies par an donc 740 par chat parents
vous allez me dire c'est pas beaucoup
maintenant vous allez multiplié sa part
2 millions parce que c'est l'estimation
basse je prends même pas 6 millions ce
serait oui c'est pas la peine mais
disons vous multipliez sa part 2
millions de chats sauvages vous avez
1500 milliards de petites proies parents
consommée par la population de 2
millions de chats sauvages
quand vous avez quand vous commencez
atteindre des chiffres comme ça qui sont
astronomiques c'est qu'il ya clairement
un problème est que l'écosystème y
tiendra plus très longtemps donc si vous
voulez les solutions que propose la
conservation compassionnel c'est des
solutions donc typiquement la
stérilisation ou la mise en refuge chez
les solutions qu aurait été efficace au
début du problème c'est quand il n'y
avait pas encore une population énorme
de chats sauvages et que bah c'était
plus ou moins contrôlable parce que du
coup effectivement on pouvait capturer
les animaux vous pouvez les stériliser
ça va pas vous prendre trop de temps ni
trop d'argent parce qu'il faut quand
même se rendre à l'évidence que
stériliser 2 millions ou 6 millions
parce que c'est ça ravier estimation il
ya aucun moyen de leur sens et de chats
sauvages ça va quand même vous coûter un
bras et le gouvernement australien étant
ce qu'il est il est fort probable qu'il
veut seulement aucune envie de payer
pour ce genre de choses et c'est
certainement pas le contribuable qui va
mettre la main à la poche donc dans ce
genre de cas si vous voulez il n'y a
plus il y a plus grand chose d'autre à
faire le seul moyen de réguler la
population s'est effectivement
de tuer la majeure partie de l'espèce
invasive sachant qu'en plus on
australien notre problème c'est qu'on a
aussi introduit le renard le renard qui
lui aussi près d'ath beaucoup à les
petites proies en australie et voilà
donc vous avez encore un problème
supplémentaire ajouté à sa wii
l'australienne a pas mal de soucis en ce
moment au niveau conservation bref donc
voilà donc la pondération compassionnel
si vous voulez avec ce principe de ne
pas faire de mal elle a une réponse mais
lorsqu'on est dans un cas encore très
très tôt si vous voulez dans le temps le
problème des espèces invasives avant que
la situation devienne critique quand la
situation devient critique c'est
clairement plus la réponse appropriée il
va falloir faire une action qui aura un
effet maintenant et
dans ce qui se passe avec l'écosystème
australien typiquement plus à enlever
deux chats de l'équation plus votre
population va survivre mais vous avez
intérêt à le faire maintenant pour être
sûr que les espèces survivent si vous
attendez encore quelques années pour
beaucoup d'espèces ce sera fini et c'est
un peu c'est un peu ce qu'on regrette
voilà donc c'est le premier problème que
joue avec la conservation compassionnel
c'est que collectivement c'est très bien
d'avoir de la compassion pour les
animaux et ce serait mieux de ne pas
avoir à tuer les animaux mais il ya des
cas où par si on veut sauver le reste et
éviter que justement ces espèces
invasives ne fasse trop de mal ou reste
des espèces parce que là pour le coup
c'est effectivement comme ça ou
choisissez quoi de faire du mal à des
espèces invasives ou de faire du mal aux
espèces qui sont déjà là sur place si
les voilà il ya vous choisissez l'un ou
l'autre mais pourrait pas sauver tout le
monde est menacé c'est fini c'est trop
tard donc vous allez devoir choisir le
moins pire en quelque sorte eva la
conservation traditionnel dit de virer
l'espèce invasive et voilà décidé de
sauver leur s maximum parce que c'est
vrai que quand on regarde les choses
logiquement le chat domestique on l'a
peu près sur tous les continents ce
serait un peu stupide de de sacrifier
les espèces endémiques australienne au
profit du chat domestique qui au final
est très répandue voilà donc c'est
c'est un peu la réflexion qu'on a en
conservation généralement on essaie de
voir le moins pire des deux cantons
quand on peut et qui m'a sauvé on sauve
ce qu'on peut donc ça c'était le premier
point de la conservation compassionnel
et c'est la premier point sur lequel les
conservationnistes les gens s'occupant
de conservation de manière
traditionnelle et ceux qui font ça de
manière optionnelle commencent à se
bouffer le nez parce que voilà c'est
vraiment le premier point de désaccord
entre les deux
le deuxième point c'est les individus
sont importants donc à opposer aux
populations évidemment pour être bien
sûr qu'on se pose bien à la conservation
traditionnels pour ce faire la
conservation
compassionnel a d'ailleurs ajouté de
nouvelles définitions
les individus ne sont plus appelés
individus mais c'est des individus de la
faune pour traduire ça de manière assez
rapide et les populations ou espèces ne
sont plus les populations ou des espèces
mais sont des collectivités faunistique
ou phonique ou comme vous le sentez et
donc les individus sont des membres des
collectivités phonique ou faunistique
voilà alors quand on commence à
redéfinir des mots c'est que
généralement ça va pas bien mais pas
trop besoin de nouvelles définitions le
principe ici en fait c'est que l'animal
dans la conservation compassionnel à
plus ou moins un statut équivalent à
celui de l'humain donc si au lieu de
populations et d'espèces vous portez
vous parler maintenant de collectivités
ça va amener un petit peu ça va vous
évoquez l'humain en quelque sorte et
c'est un peu le but recherché c'est que
la conservation compassionnel situe
l'animal au même niveau que l'humain
avec les mêmes droits et c'est pour ça
que non les principes de la conservation
compassionnel on ne doit pas tuer les
animaux ne doit pas leur faire de mal de
moi parce que bah ils ont les mêmes
droits qu'un être humain et donc on n'a
pas de droit sur eux et on n'a pas le
droit de réguler leur population à cause
de ça voilà parce que qui sommes-nous
après tout pour réguler leur population
voilà dans ce qu'ils disent ce sera un
peu comme jouer à dieu et décider de qui
doit vivre et qui doit mourir c'est vrai
que est dit comme ça effectivement c'est
pas très agréable vous noterez quand
même un point important c'est que
écosystèmes lui n'a pas été redéfinies
donc on a une fois de plus un désintérêt
clair pour les relations trophique ce
qui m'inquiète un petit peu d'ailleurs
dans ce genre de la conservation
compassionnel c'est qu'il ya un
désintérêt total pour les relations
trophic et c'est quand même le plus
important d'un écosystème parce que mine
de rien la définition d'une espèce de
base c'est une définition qui se fait
par rapport aux autres espèces parce que
si vous regardez par exemple la
définition du lion à lyon vous allez
généralement avoir un truc comme quoi le
lion mange des gazelles donc en fait on
la définit par rapport aux par rapport à
ce qu'ils mangent en l'occurrence une
autre espèce donc rien que dans la
définition des espèces elles sont déjà
définis comme étant vivante par rapport
à quelque chose d'autre donc ça
m'inquiète un petit peu voilà de ne pas
parler de relation comme ça dans les
écosystèmes dans quand on essaie de
parler de conservation pour moi c'est
vrai c'est un gros manque dans cette
définition ces écosystèmes et ses
relations qui apparaissent dans les
écosystèmes entre les espèces ou entre
les populations vers
une autre chose qui est important dans
la conservation traditionnel cette fois
ci c'est que une espèce la raison pour
laquelle elle ne doit pas s'éteindre
vous allez me dire bah peut-être parce
que pour que les descendants pour que
nos descendants puissent encore les voir
et en profiter pour que n'est pas
d'écraser tout ce qui se passe autour de
nous tout simplement parce qu'on a une
responsabilité envers les espèces qui
sont autour de nous je voudrais que ces
valides comme point effectivement mais
ce qui est important pour moi dans la
définition d'une espèce c'est qu'une
espèce c'est quoi c'est une somme de
gênes et allen qui ensemble sont
capables de se reproduire de d'avoir une
descendance et surtout ont engrangé
toute une histoire évolutive derrière
eux qui du coup se retrouvent dans ce
génome avec l'extinction en fait de
cette espèce et bien tout simplement
c'est la fin d'une histoire à la fin
d'une histoire évolutive et
c'est une histoire qu'on aura plus lier
avec nous et je trouve ça vraiment
dommage de se priver de ce genre de
choses alors qu'on est tout à fait
capable de préserver les espèces sachant
qu'en plus c'est un peu notre faute
effectivement de leur extinction
généralement jeu ce serait bien
d'essayer quand même de préserver ces
histoires qui sont tout autour de nous
sont d histoire évolutive et qui sont
extraits demande intéressante
même si la ville l'évolution humaine
elle-même et ça j'ai un peu l'impression
aussi que dans la la conservation
compassionnel on oublie un peu vite que
ces espèces finalement qu'on laisse à la
la proie de base des espèces invasives
comme les chats typiquement eh ben on
s'en préoccupe pas tant que ça et alors
qu'on évite d'agir et ou alors qu'on se
dit qu'on va rester en retrait en
laissant possiblement à l'écosystème se
gérer lui même mais en fait on se prive
volontairement de toutes ces histoires
et on les laisse volontairement
s'éteindre et ça c'est aussi quelque
chose qui me dérange extrêmement fort
pour passer au point numéro 3 cette fois
ci on a parlé d'inclusivité donc
inclusivité de tous les individus
donc pour la conservation dans le dans
lequel conservation compassionnel on va
prendre en compte tous les individus
dont une population et n'a aucun qui va
être mis de côté et on va essayer de
tous les soigner de tous ont occupé leur
accorder le même niveau de respect ou
alors c'est une notion qui est très
noble 1 comme tout ce que fait la
conservation compassionnel d'ailleurs il
ya de grandes notions d'éthique daher et
c'est important de l'été
qu'effectivement mais encore une fois il
ya il ya un petit souci c'est que en
conservation traditionnel chaque membre
de la population qu'on souhaite sauver
effectivement considérer
intéressant parce que surtout dans les
populations très réduite on va avoir
besoin du maximum d'individus président
celui une espèce est généralement plus
vous avez d'individus encore vivant plus
vous avez de chance de sauver votre
espèce mais on va pas se voiler la face
certains individus de cette population
que vous allez récupérer vont être plus
utiles que d'autres programmes de
conservation que vous allez mettre en
place pourquoi et bien tout simplement
parce que certains individus ont certes
un génome qui vont être très diversifié
qui vont proposer des allèles un peu
différent du reste peut-être ou alors
des des choses qui vont faire en sorte
qu'elles vont être plus utile pour la
production par exemple celui-là est un
est une meilleure celle là est une
meilleure mère porteuse qu'une autre ce
qui va du coup permettre peut-être de
faire parvenir un embryon à terme alors
qu'une autre a des problèmes pour la
reproduction celle là sera peut-être
moins utiles au programme de
reproduction et lorsqu'il s'agit de
faire un choix parce que ça arrive
souvent qu'il va falloir privilégier
l'un ou l'autre des individus de cette
population pour parfois arriver à faire
survivre à la population eh ben on va
évidemment choisir l'animal qui va être
le plus utile pour le couloir de
consommation que ce soit pour le faire
se reproduire avec d'autres pour avoir
les meilleures combinaisons génétiques
possible
ou tout simplement pour sa survie et
quand par exemple on doit choisir entre
faire survivre un individu ou un autre
on va choisir en fonction de son utilité
pour le programme de conservation dans
ces cas là et je sais que c'est triste à
dire mais le problème c'est qu'en
conservation on n'a pas beaucoup de sous
et vous pouvez pas sauver tout le monde
c'est juste pas possible vous avez des
refuges qui sont pleins à craquer
d'animal'z essayer de faire ce que vous
pouvez vous essayer de les admettre au
maximum jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait plus de
place jusqu'à ce que vous ayez plus
nourriture qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous
ayez plus rien pour les soigner plus
d'outils médicaux plus rien plus
personne puis de plus de bras à plus de
plus personne pour nettoyer les cages
mais mais il ya un moment où vous pouvez
plus et malheureusement le prochain
animal qui va se présenter à la porte et
qui aura besoin de soins mais tu as
peut-être qu'on lui dira non parce qu'il
y aura plus de place c'est un peu comme
si vous voulez l'histoire des lits
médicaux là dans la dernière crise
sanitaire qu'on a eu
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand il ya plus de
places en réa alors oui on installe de
nouveaux lits on essaie de faire avec ce
qu'on a en outre des gymnases mais un
moment peu plus quand vous avez beaucoup
trop de monde bah y'en a qui seront
soignés peut-être un peu moins bien que
les autres parce que là ils ont pas
accès aux mêmes hôpitaux et c'est triste
à dire mais du coup dans ces cas là pour
les animaux vous faites un choix vous
choisissez de sauver celui qui a le plus
de chance de survie peut-être programme
de conservation et le problème de la
conservation compassionnel dans ces cas
là c'est que quelle que soit l'individu
il va il va avoir droit à la même chose
donc par exemple si vous avez deux deux
animaux qui rentrent en même temps et
l'un va être très utile pour avoir une
conservation mais l'autre ne le sera pas
du tout eh ben ça va être tiré à pile ou
face en quelque sorte et on va pas juste
privilégié celui qui pourrait être
beaucoup plus utile par rapport à
l'autre et je sais c'est triste à dire
mais il ya des fois où il faut faire un
choix est laissé tout problème de la
conservation et de ce qu'on nous donne
pour faire de la conservation des fois
c'est pas c'est pas simple la
conservation c'est un métier difficile
qui demande beaucoup de force de
caractère qui qui demande d'accepter
cueilli les échecs qu'on n'arrive pas à
sauver tout le monde malgré tout on doit
continuer à faire des efforts pour en
sauver un maximum mais mais c'est pas
c'est pas facile tous les jours et c'est
il faut bien se rendre compte que la
conservation c'est un métier à part
entière et que ça s'invente
un autre problème avec l'inclusivité
c'est que l'inclusivité violence et que
pour les animaux dans la définition
aussi c'est à dire que là on en parle de
l'actualité tous les individus mais on a
défini en eau que les individus
s'étaient des animaux et pas n'importe
lesquels aussi c'est que généralement la
publicité il va se faire sur des animaux
qui sont
qui font partie de la biodiversité
disney donc typiquement les grands
mammifères et les oiseaux aussi ses
jolies les oiseaux rendu sympa et
peut-être les jusqu au crocodile d'un
peut-être si vous avez de la chance mais
les plantes les insectes tous les petits
trucs là qui ressemble à rien bah non
non donc larmes en clarté big man enfin
vous prendre un mammifère couvert de tic
on va le récupérer on va essayer de
soignant va lui enlever les tic et puis
puis voilà on va tuer les parasites en
quelques sortes et la conservation
compassionnel dans ces cas là ne
s'intéresse pas vraiment aux parasites
retour on s'en fiche le problème c'est
que si un jour le parasite c'est lui qui
en est à 2
en voie d'extinction avec disparition
bas la conservation compassionnel va pas
vraiment prendre ça en compte la sauver
l'autre animal l'autre animal qui est
gentil kiev le filet mignon la tique
peut aller se faire voir clairement
c'est un peu le problème c'est que la
conservation compassionnel va s'occuper
des animaux qui sont jolis qu'ils sont
sympas qui sont mignons le reste ça peut
aller se revoir et donc là c'est pour
moi c'est un autre gros souci c'est à
dire que les principaux managers partie
des programmes de co sarah sûrement dans
le monde ça se fait sur des espèces mais
qui sont pas belles à voir en fait
qu'ils sont pas présentés au grand
public parce que tout simplement
personne personne n'a envie de préserver
ces trucs là et tout le monde s'en fiche
vous vous demandez à quelqu'un d'aller
préserver un accueil aubeterre au fin
fond de l'amazonie vous dire mais ça
sert à rien qu'est ce que j'en ai à
fiesch j'ai assez ce coléoptère il
m'intéresse pas il est là bas y vit
là-bas sur son arbre là et puis moi je
vis ici de toute façon je ne vois pas
l'intérêt donc ce que vous allez faire
quand vous faites de la conservation
vous allez proposer en fait de
sauvegarder une espèce qui est qu'on va
appeler une espèce parapluie qui va
avoir une aire de répartition
très important dans laquelle on va
retrouver les aires de répartition
d'autres espèces qui elles sont en voie
de disparition ou d'extinction qui sont
plus petites que qui n'intéresse
personne à part les gens qui font de la
conservation peut être mais mais qui
sont là et qui ont besoin qu'on les
protège et donc en protégeant par
exemple je sais pas le marquer en
amérique du sud ou bien le jaguar donc
ces grands animaux emblématiques et en
protégeant leur aire de répartition vous
allez pouvoir protéger toutes les
espèces qui sont à l'intérieur de ces
aires de répartition ça c'est espèce
parapluie et on va les utiliser comme
des espèces emblème pour pouvoir aller
faire
demander au grand public ou aux
gouvernements des sous pour protéger ces
zones là le problème de la comparse de
la conservation compassionnel sait
qu'elle va s'intéresser uniquement aux
espèces qui sont charismatiques aux
grandes espèces aux autres qu'ils sont
mignons et elle va pas vraiment
s'intéresser au reste à toutes les
espèces qui sont en dessous parce que ba
final on s'en fiche et c'est vrai que
ces espèces là elles donnent pas tous
donc j'imagine qu'on sait un
terrassement bref c'est un autre débat
donc tout ça pour vous dire que
l'inclusivité oui mais visiblement pas
pour tout le monde semblerait que les
deux poids deux mesures donc ça c'est un
autre problème pour moi de 7 ce type de
conservation
maintenant le dernier point le point
numéro 4 et la coexistence pacifique car
c'est la coexistence pacifique entre
humains et animaux
évidemment
comme toujours on ne parle pas de
plantes 1 parce que là on parle de la
coexistence pacifique uniquement entre
l'humain et l'animal
évidemment on considère pas les animaux
comme les tickets à la coexistence
pacifique entre l'homme et l'éthique ça
vous pouvez laisser tomber c'est pas la
peine on va lui retirer le problème de
ce truc là encore c'est que il va
falloir être réaliste à un moment dans
la nature de base les relations
trophique donc entre les espèces c'est
pas beau à voir on est quand même sur
des relations c'est plus du style
justement je suis mangé ou je te
parasites je suis parasites et voilà
donc on n'est pas voilà c'est pas
fondard tous les jours d'être dans la
nature tout seul d'être une petite
espèce qui essaie de se débrouiller pour
survivre ou une petite individus de
cette espèce à la nature c'est pas beau
à voir c'est un oui ça a l'air beau de
loin et puis c'est joli les
documentaires qu'on vous montre à la
télé c'est très beau mais la nature
c'est sale et ça peut être très très
sale il faut bien prendre ça en compte
la coexistence pacifique entre deux
espèces ou oui elles vont signoret au
pire si si vraiment c'est des espèces
qui n'ont aucun intérêt à se côtoyer
effectivement et monsignore mais à part
ça vous n'allez pas demander clairement
aux chats domestiques d'avoir une
coexistence pacifique avec les petits
mammifères du coin ça va pas se passer
comme ça
alors niveau de la coexistence pacifique
il ya un petit problème pour moi et je
l'illustré avec cet exemple il ya une
île dont qui s'appelle l'île de gau sur
à laquelle il ya et
albatros et plusieurs espèces qui
nichent sur stella et des espèces
d'albatros qui sont en danger critique
d'extinction évidemment de la drogue et
sur cette île l'humain introduit
pas forcément volontairement mais en
tout cas il introduit la souris donc je
m'excuse joris van hecke qui s'est
répandu sur l'île et qui depuis trouvé
comme or pas les oeufs et les poussins
des albatros qui sont laissés sans
surveillance par les parents le temps
qu'il aille chercher de quoi manger du
coup les souris dévore vivent les
poussins d'albatros alors c'est un peu
corse et c'est comme ça et la réponse
des personnes qui font de la
conservation compassionnel à cette
question en disant mais vous feriez vous
allez faire quoi pour cette situation
qui devient critique sur l'île parce
qu'on parle quand même des espèces en
voie d'extinction la qui se font bouffer
par une espèce qui elle n'est pas du
tout en voie d'extinction à la souris
mus mu plus elle est quand même répandu
à travers le globe donc on est d'accord
que c'est pas une espèce
voilà virer les souris de lille ne va
pas causer leur disparition par contre
laissé les souris sur l'île va causer
l'extinction des abattages
donc voilà pour moi le problème à part
très complexe le jeu serait amassé
rapidement résolu mais mais visiblement
pour des légendes de conservation
compassionnel la réponse était tout
simplement de laisser la nature suivre
son cours et de laisser les souris sur
l'île parce que bon on va pas jouer à
dieu et on va les laisser se débrouiller
tout seul et on fait cette réponse est
motivée par le fait que les écosystèmes
sont capables de se réguler tout seul et
du coup l'homme n'a pas à intervenir
dans ces cas là parce que les
écosystèmes sont tout à fait capables de
se débrouiller les espèces sont tout à
fait capables de se réguler tout seul et
n'ont pas besoin de nous alors je dirais
dans la plupart des cas effectivement
c'est le cas les écosystèmes n'ont pas
attendu la venue de l'homme pour se
débrouiller tout seul alors donné une
conscience évidemment mais voilà les
autres espèces savent se débrouiller
sans nous généralement puis bon
effectivement il va il va bien falloir
laisser la nature suivre son cours dans
certains dans certains cas mais plat
dans ce cas là qui est bien spécifique
c'est l'homme qui a introduit la soriq
sur l'île et qui du coup est la cause de
l'extinction des albatros le moins que
l'on puisse faire dans ces cas là ce
sera quand même de réparer la bêtise
avant de causer l'extinction d'autres
espèces on a déjà causé l'extinction de
suffisamment d'espèces en plus ce serait
bien d'éviter de continuer il semblerait
que ce ne soit pas trop le mode de
pensée de gens qui font la conservation
compassionnel et c'est un peu dommage
est-ce que du coup
ça va promouvoir l'extraction des
albatros
donc voilà c'est la coexistence
pacifique prévoit en fait comme dans le
premier principe de ne pas faire de mal
aux animaux et de les laisser se
débrouiller tout seul alors en un sens
oui mais il ya quand même des moments où
je pense que voilà il faut prendre les
choses au cas par cas et comme pour les
albatros il faut savoir quand on fait de
la conservation quand et comment agir
pour moi c'est ça qui manque ici et le
gros problème aussi de ce dernier point
avec la coexistence pacifique
l'autre problème de la coexistence
pacifique c'est que effectivement en
tant qu'humain on devrait essayer de
vivre en harmonie avec la nature mais on
est d'accord que c'est une utopie vivre
en harmonie avec la nature on n'est pas
des elfes vivent dans des cabanes dans
les bois jusqu'à preuve du contraire il
ya des intérêts des intérêts financiers
en jeu pour beaucoup de choses et il ya
des gens qui tout simplement aux besoins
de la nature aussi pour survivre je vous
donne un exemple imaginer une forêt
alors d'habitants en afrique donc c'est
assez simple pour moi de voir un peu ce
qui se passe ici mais il y à des
endroits kenya en ouganda n'importe où
où les populations vont se basé
exclusivement sur ce qu'ils peuvent
récupérer dans les forêts alentours puis
notamment sur la viande de brousse donc
la bouche mythe pour se nourrir et pour
avoir une source de protéines parce que
ben y'a pas grand chose d'autre autour
de chez eux et il n'y a pas grand chose
qu'ils puissent non plus donc ils
peuvent cultiver deux trois trucs jouer
mais c'est pas là pas vraiment de terre
arable comme on va avoir en en europe 1
le climat n'est pas le même donc ils
vont se baser sur ce qu'ils vont réussir
à trouver autour de chez eux il c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'ils ont des tas de
problèmes avec
certains parasites et certaines
bactéries qui vont se retrouver dans les
dents les animaux qui mange parce qu'ils
chassent beaucoup de choses il parfois
ils chassent pas les bons trucs
typiquement les choses sont maintenant
imaginez que vous avez une espèce qui
est en danger critique d'extinction de
ces forêts vous avez plusieurs villages
autour de cette forêt et vous dites à
ces villages bon ben maintenant va
falloir vivre en coexistence pacifique
avec ce qu'ils trouvent dans la forêt
non vous n'avez plus droit de choses et
nous attend parce que l'espèce est en
voie de disparation de l'extinction ou
alors les légats dans les villages ils
vont vous regardez ils vont vous dire
d'aller vous faire voir proprement 1
tout simplement parce que
la forêt et son contenu donc les animaux
qui sont en train de manger c'est leur
seule chance de survie c'est à dire
qu'ils n'ont pas accès à des
supermarchés on est d'accord que la vie
ces communautés là c'est pas facile
c'est cesser des populations qui vont
avoir besoin de cette viande de gauche
pour survivre au jour le jour donc si
vous leur coupait soudainement tout
accès à la forêt vous mettez une
barrière autour vous l'a déclarée
réserve naturelle où vous voulez vous
mettez des miradors mettez des gardes tu
es ce que voulaient au tour en fait aux
condamnés ces populations alors le choix
se pose dans ces cas là est-ce que vous
avez privilégié les populations humaines
ou est-ce que vous allez privilégier la
survie de l'espèce qui est en voie de
disparition ou l'extinction qui est ce
que vous choisissez pour quel camp vous
jouez c'est ça le truc et dans ces cas
là vous pouvez pas vraiment choisir de
commencer car il va falloir faire un
compromis et c'est un peu le problème de
la coexistence pacifique c'est que avec
cette coexistence pacifique qui a pas de
compromis possible c'est à dire que vous
arrêtez tout simplement de choper les
bestioles et de les tuer les utiliser
pour que vous en fait c'est tout y'a pas
de ya pas de demi-mesure c'est fini on
met une barrière autour voilà vous y
toucher plus il ya beaucoup de cas oui
c'est pas possible en fait donc ce que
fait ce que font les gens dans la
conservation traditionnelle dans ces cas
là c'est qu'ils vont réunir autour d'une
table tous les acteurs qui ont quelque
chose à voir avec l'espèce en question
c'est à dire qu'on va mettre autour
d'une table tous les gens qui vont avoir
un intérêt sur le terrain par exemple
sur lequel vit l'espèce intéressés
donc ça peut être fière du terrain ça
peut être le gars qui a envie d'acheter
le terrain ça peut être des gens qui
passent régulièrement ça peut être un
promoteur immobilier qui lui est cher
françois un truc que ça peut être la
digne qui veut y faire passer une route
ça peut être plein de choses et vous
allez aussi mettre tous les gens qui ont
des intérêts économiques ou simplement
de survivre
dans l'espèce en question ça peut être
les gens qui utilisent comme viande de
brousse ça peut être d'autres qui vont
la chasse et le bras koné va pour
revendre des morceaux que soient les
cornes de rhinos où les défenses
d'éléphants techniquement ça peut être
aussi pour le commerce des nouveaux
animaux de compagnie par exemple un des
perroquets qui sont capturés alors à
l'état deux fois l'état de poussins dans
les nids en amazonie ça peut être plein
de choses donc tous les gens qui ont un
intérêt dans cet endroit où dans cette
espèce vont être réunis autour d'une
table on va essayer de voir ce que
chacun ce dont chacun a besoin en fait
pour survivre que ce soit les les gens
qui vont crever de faim ou les les
multinationales qui ont un intérêt dans
la chose et on va leur dire bah voilà
c'est simple l'espèce elle en a encore
pour cinq ans après il n'y a plus rien
alors soit vous choisissez nous aider
maintenant soit base de toute façon dans
cinq ans vous allez être mis au pied du
mur et puis bah va falloir choisir
falloir faire autre chose vous aurez
plus le choix de toute façon donc si on
essaye de travailler ensemble maintenant
il ya peut-être moyen de préserver
l'espèce tout en continuant à l'utiliser
mais de manière raisonnée pour ce que
vous voulez faire c'est à dire que vous
n'allez pas la pousser dans ses derniers
retranchements et la sphère s'éteindront
tuant jusqu'au dernier des individus on
va mettre en place un programme qui va
permettre de faire survivre l'espèce
tout en permettant de l'utiliser en même
temps et donc en faisant ce genre de
chose en réunissant tout le monde autour
d'une table et en essayant de discuter
des principes avec lesquels vous allez
pouvoir sauvegarder cette espèce tout en
continuant à l'utiliser et bien vous
fait finalement survivre l'espèce alors
oui c'est un compromis oui on aimerait
bien dans le meilleur des mondes ce
serait formidable faire clôturer
l'endroit effectivement et faire en
sorte que plus personne n'y entrent pour
que l'espèce se développe à loisir
mais ça c'est utopique ça c'est quelque
chose qui se fait dans les rêves mais
d'un monde réel ça se passe pas comme ça
donc le tueur est l'endroit le lendemain
il la clôture est défoncée parce que les
gens ont besoin d'y rentrer est ce qu'il
vaut mieux pas essayé de se les alliés
mais même si c'est la base de compromis
pour voir au final sauvegarder les
espèces qui vous intéressent donc c'est
vraiment cette approche là qu'on essaie
de prendre maintenant dans la
conservation traditionnels pour que
voilà tous les acteurs qui ont un
intérêt dans l'espèce ou dans l'endroit
puisse travailler deux concerts à la
sauvegarde de l'espèce et à son
utilisation mois mais raisonnée cette
fois-là et généralement ça se passe
assez bien quand on arrive à avoir tout
le monde ensemble ça finit par pardonner
de bons trucs et il ya des programmes
qui se met en place qui sont assez
formidable et qui permettent d'ailleurs
d'aider les populations sur place car
par exemple si vous essayez de créer une
réserve qui soit à moitié ouverts tous
savent quelque chose d'une spa vous
pouvez par exemple employer des gens des
villages des alentours pour bat pour
garder la réserve pour faire le suivi
des populations animales pour donc vous
essayer de l'utiliser les ressources que
vous avez sur place pour travailler au
mieux à la sauvegarde de l'espèce et
tout en permettant aux gens va de
continuer à l'utiliser et surtout d'en
tirer un bénéfice en quelque sorte et
donc c'est grâce à ce bénéfice pour les
populations locales et pour les jeux
valve et compagnie les multinationales
ce que vous voulez que votre programme
il va marcher donc cette idée de
coexistence pacifique où il n'y a pas de
compromis possible pour moi c'est une
aberration dans le monde où nous vivons
c'est une jolie utopie mais ça ne se
fera jamais
malheureusement il va falloir être
réaliste un amant on a fini les quatre
points de la conservation compassionnel
j'espère que ce petit tour d'horizon de
ce que c'est et comment en conservation
traditionnel on envisage les choses au
contraire de la conservation
compassionnel sa pub vous éclairer un
petit peu sur ce qui se passait quels
sont les petits problèmes que moi je
vois avec ce concept
si vous devez retenir un truc retenez
que la conservation c'est un boulot à
temps plein c'est compliqué c'est
difficile ça demande beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup investissements et beaucoup de
connaissances et ça ne se fait pas du
jour au lendemain et ça se fait pas
uniquement grâce à de bons et de grands
sentiments alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de notions d'éthique dans la
conservation et on l on fait très
attention au bien-être des animaux des
populations quand on doit les amener en
captivité ces animaux mais heureusement
pour l'or pour leur sauvegarde mais on
ne dit pas non plus dans un monde de
bisounours et il ya un moment où il va
falloir mettre les mains dans le
cambouis et agir si on veut sauvegarder
des espèces et des fois agir et
sauvegarder des espèces sa demande d'en
tuer d'autres qui sont invasive c'est
sale c'est moche mais c'est nécessaire
et malheureusement des fois on n'a pas
vraiment le choix de la méthode parce
qu'il n'y a plus que ça qui nous reste
quand la situation a atteint un niveau
critique
si vous avez des questions évidemment
c'est dans les commentaires en dessous
n'hésitez pas j'imagine que le sujet
fera pas mal d bah moi ça m'intéresse
c'est juste de vous donner voilà un
petit aperçu de ce que c'était de ce que
j'en pensais je pense que c'est un sujet
qui finira par se démocratiser assez
rapidement sur les réseaux dans les
prochaines années donc voilà ça peut
vous donner les bases de ce que c'est
comme envoyer chose
à très bientôt sur la chaîne pour de
nouvelles aventures avec des plumes
[Musique]